Hello everybody, I'm VOA's Rebecca Ward for Going Green.
The U.S. Congress, along with President Barack Obama,...
...have been considering legislation to cap carbon emissions.
But what about the damage that's already been done by pollution?
Hollywood actress Ashley Judd and host of Animal Planet's "Corwin's Quest", Jeff Corwin,...
...recently appeared before Congress to appeal for funding for wildlife protection.
We caught up with them at the Hart Senate Building here in Washington...
...where they were more than happy to talk about their conservation concerns.
My testimony today was on behalf of defenders of wildlife...
...which is advocating that in the global warming bill...
...that will hopefully be passed,...
...5% of the revenue generated from cap and trade, carbon dioxide emissions...
...will be used to protect and restore wildlife and ecosystems.
Really important today is that we're stressing the fact that it's not just reducing global warming...
...but that we address the impact already felt on the ground...
...and the impact that will continue to reverberate for centuries.
For biologist Jeff Corwin, the effects of climate change are personal.
My daughter Maya and my daughter Marina...
...the truth is that when they are young women,...
...it's very likely that 30% of the wildlife alive today,...
...the species, not that we just cherish,...
...but that we depend upon economically for our survival, will not be here.
I mean, try to imagine that.
That's one species of life disappearing today every 20 minutes.